in a world where Arrested Development
can trace his Origins back to man bites
dog um you guys have you're very
schooled in your subject matter um yeah
we watched a lot of growing up I
mean we were just Fanatics I mean I
watch you know it was like Doby Gillis
is in there too and so is lost in space
and you
know Island and many amongst your
influences many Scorsese films as well
me many Scorsese films
um who who doesn't every scor yes every
everybody for the record everybody loves
Barton sces yes everybody does he's one
of the reasons one of the biggest
reasons that we're sitting up here right
it's the the influence of his movies and
you know it's interesting because uh uh
you know my daughter runs my social
media account the way his daughter runs
his social media account and we saw this
cute video he did with his dog and we
happen to have an identical dog schn
yeah they're both schneer and I thought
this is hilarious this could be really
cute and his video is him his video is
him talking to his dog he's coaching it
through you know like he's train he like
it's going to do a part for him and his
dog's name is his dog's name is
Oscar uh and my daughter was like that's
funny she was like what if our dog's
name was box office and I went oh that's
funny that's
cute uh and then you know we posted it
on Tik Tok like a week we do a bunch of
Tik Tok videos together it's like how I
stay connected to my daughter um you
know she has all these funny ideas and
we're trying all this all the time
and we posted it and then like people
discovered it like a week after we
posted it so you posted you're like that
was fun did something with the kids life
is good yeah and then uh you know I
think people conflated the timing of
when they discovered it with this movie
which was not the intention this was
just like a broad appeal joke you know
it's like he's got a funny dog named
Oscar I've got a little schneer named
box office and you know storm
ensues yeah it wasn't I I mean when I
saw it I wasn't like oh he got him he
sure got him I was like oh
that's adorable the internet on the
other hand had different ideas they did
you I got internetted
yes they internetted all over your face
neck and
chest this is brought to you by that
kevinsmith club.com that's right man if
you can't get enough of the sound of my
voice then you could surf on over to
thatkevinsmith club.com join up that
kevinsmith club.com what are you waiting
for join the club